a farm supply store carries four
different brands of pesticide each brand
sells pesticide of a different
concentration and each brand also has a
different size of bottle so here we have
the different brands they give us the
bottle size the concentration so that's
the percentage of this fluid volume that
is actually that is actually pesticide
that's actually active ingredient and
then they tell us the price per bottle
and they ask us if we want the most
active ingredient for our money you
should spend your money on bottles of
brand
bottles of brand question mark so let's
just think about which of these which of
these brands gives us the most active
ingredient for our money and i encourage
you to pause this video and try to think
about this on your own
well let's just think about how much
active ingredient let's first think
about active
active ingredient
ingredient
let's think about active ingredient per
i'll just write in gree in greed for
short ingredient per
per bottle
and i'll do this in milliliters
so we have 375 milliliters 65 percent of
which is going to be active so 65
percent of 375 is
so 0.65
times
gets us 243.75
273 273.75
milliliters of active ingredient per
bottle
now how much is that active ingredient
what is going to be the active
ingredient
ingredient per dollar here
per dollar well you could just reason
through it you say oh i have 273.75
ml's for 22 dollars so if i want per
dollar i'll just divide this by 22.
so you divide so let me say if i just do
that that's my previous answer which is
that divided by 22
gets me and i'll just round to the
nearest penny at
11.8 cents
this is 11
let me see this is mls 11
once again this isn't mls not dollars so
i took this this is mls per bottle
milliliters per bottle divided by 22
dollars per bottle gets us 11.07
ml per dollar actually let me write it
that way ml's
per
dollar just so we can keep track of the
unit this is ml's
per bottle now another way that we could
have thought about it is look you had
273.75
ml
per bottle
per bottle we want to get it to mls
per dollar
so we want to get rid of a bottle in the
denominator so we would want to multiply
it by something with bottles in the
numerator and we want to introduce a
dollar in the denominator so it would be
bottles per
dollar and how many bottles are there
per dollar or another way to think about
it is one bottle is 22 dollars so you
multiply 23.75 times 1 over 22 you would
get 11.07
and that cancels with that milliliters
per
dollar and notice this is you could have
done this through common sense this is
equivalent to just dividing this is how
much you get for 22 dollar bottle
divided by 22 dollars you get how much
you're getting or you get the express or
you get the quantity or the milliliters
per dollar but either way let's do it
for the rest of them
so for this one right over here in
general we can to figure this out we
just have to multiply the concentration
times the bottle size and then divide it
by the price so let's just do that for
the next three
so we have we the concentration is 35
0.35
whoops
so 0.35
times
750 so this expression is going to give
us the milliliters of active ingredient
and then we can divide by the cost per
bottle
and we're going to get so this is 12.5
milliliters per dollar so this one is
12.5
milliliters per dollar
now this next one they give it they give
us 1 liter but we know that one liter is
equal to one thousand
milliliters seventy-five percent of that
is going to be active ingredient so
we're going to have 750 milliliters of
active ingredient and it's going to cost
68 so we just divide this by 68
and we get
milliliters divided by 68
it gets us 11 and if we round three
cents
or not we're in milliliters 11.03
milliliters
per
dollar have to be very careful
uh
this is milliliters per dollar the whole
point of this is to keep track of the
units so that this isn't dollars this is
milliliters per dollar
and then finally 1.5 liters well times
times 1000
milliliters per liter
this would give us 1500
milliliters
30 percent of which is an act is active
so 30 of 1500 milliliters that's 450
milliliters and then we can divide that
by 40.
so 450 divided by 40.
gets us to 11.25 milliliters per dollar
11.25
milliliters per dollar
so which one is the best deal well the
best deal is one where i get the most
milliliters per dollar and that's brand
b right over here i get 12.5 milliliters
per
dollar i'm getting the most
pesticide for my buck